Here is an amazingly simple edge that will
help tame the curl on any edge
that isn't going to be seamed.
It's perfect for scarves and blankets
and shawls knit in plain Stockinette.
Thanks to Diana Sullivan
for introducing this technique
to machine knitters.
As you are knitting an edge that isn't
going to be seamed,
use a three-pronged tool and transfer
needles number 2,
3 and 4 to needle number 1.
You'll have two stitches on needle number
one and needle number four is now empty.
Pick up the purl bump from the row
below and fill in that needle.
And knit two rows.
Repeat this by picking up numbers 2,
3 and 4, transferring them over
to needle number one and then fill in the
emptied needle from the purl bump below.
Keep repeating this along your
knitting and you'll have an edge that not
only doesn't curl,
but it's decorative too.
I encourage you to give it a try.